alors vous dites être la forme ont
travaillé le moteur de mon existence mon
opium ma cocaïne mon prozac consacré
plaît oui ah ben oui oui elle aime jouer
arrêtez pas alors on va parler de vous
on va voir un peu votre vie qui est
assez extraordinaire
ils ont du talent la télévision c'est
clair on dit au début alors vous êtes né
à nîmes
vos parents étaient protestants et ils
désespéraient d'avoir un enfant malgré
dix ans de vie commune et un jour ils
vont rendre visite à des cousins dans le
sud ouest
il s'arrête à lourdes et miracle
il a été un voyage effectivement dans
les pyrénées et puis en rentrant elle
s'y trouve est enceinte c'est comme elle
voulait avoir un fils j'ai porté des
pantalons sommerhof quoi et on appelait
bernard madoff et votre père voulait
absolument que vous passez pas couper
les cheveux parce qu'ils dînaient alors
effectivement les amis catholiques de
vos parents en attendant cette histoire
de miracle à lourdes en redemander et
votre mère précise et de twitter ou
catholiques nous avions demandé un
garçon pour les emmerder
quant aux protestants ils n'y croyaient
pas jusqu'en sixième vous vivez à
saint-geniès de malgoirès et puis
ensuite au lycée de nîmes
votre père était pharmacien comme tous
les pères de grands réalisateurs de
nouvelles vagues d'ailleurs chabrol
reste à ma science et voilà ya beaucoup
de pharmaciens votre père était fou des
gens connus et reconnus et reconnu il
disait ça ça me faisait tellement ça me
comprenaient pas les il est très
admirative à celui-là il est connu et
précis et reconnus pour vous elle est
connue comment faire je voulais être
connu aux nervis falek trop connu lui
pas seulement que de forme est reconnue
pour un meurtre en même temps donc vous
vous étiez folle de paris match à la
rubrique l est
vous découvriez les photos d audrey
hepburn de silvana mangano riz amer
marlon brando et jean babilée ouais je
suis un peu délurée déjà n'avait pas
beaucoup de latitude est quand même
assez dit ouais dans la propriété de vos
parents dans les cévennes vous aviez une
pièce que vous aviez repeinte en bleu
indigo qui était un club privé qui
s'appelait le west end club c'est le
bout du monde les cévennes à l'époque
les routes en lacets pour y arriver elle
s'appelait anita et bettina et densité
souvenez vous attendiez les garçons dans
ce club que vous aviez créé quoi oui et
je n'ai pas non mais on n'avait pas le 2
méga bits une sacrée allumeuse quand
même parce que vos parents alors ça
c'est incroyable défi mais j'étais
l'éditeur toute façon ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les parents seraient
les parents de bernadette laffont était
en proie à une sexualité intense
c'est vrai oui je crois qu'ils sont
envoyés bien en l'air ensemble mais les
rois de la sieste crapuleuse maintenant
le midi la sieste crapuleuse c'est à
dire qu'après déjeuner commission à
dormir après des années et votre père le
père était un homme charmant d'ailleurs
il traiter votre mère comme une
maîtresse
il lui éviter les tâches domestiques il
était très dévoué à sa femme et leurs
communautés pharmaciens ils avaient des
aphrodisiaques et un jour berne et de la
faune a retrouvé dans un tiroir de la
cantharide elle était c'est bien dommage
c'est l'un de leurs parents je suis à la
fois sévère et libéraux c'est à dire
très à cheval sur les horaires et en
même temps vous laisser vous habiller
comme vous voulez oui c'est marrant ça
donc j'aime m'habiller vraiment comme
une [ __ ] voilà
c'est vrai vous pouviez vous aviez vous
pouviez vous avez comme une [ __ ] mais
vraiment que meurtrier alors voilà c'est
tout alors vous vous retrouviez comme ça
anime assise seule dans un café on
devient juste au corps si vous êtes on
peut le dire l'inventrice du body d'une
certaine façon c'était des trucs de
serre et pectoraux faisais de la danse
bah oui le corps de jean les jeans fait
s'allonger pour les enfiler oui on
allait se tremper dans la méditerranée
qui ont les laisser sécher elle avec
tout un art est du mexique
vous avez une
mais bernadette lafont allumer les
maigres les mecs vous offrez un sens à
nos que vous buviez pas quand même enfin
c'était comme ça et alors il était là en
train de vous raconter des histoires en
train de vous charmer vous dit en fait
il me regardait avec un regard de
maquignons qui sont pas nommés mais
pourquoi je faisais ça pour arriver à la
question qu'est ce que tu fais j'habite
la réponse était je fais du cinéma guy
batali en italie silvana mangano à
d'accord et oui il était député à l'âge
de 16 ans
voilà à l'âge de 16 ans par un dénommé
josé qui était coiffeur et qu'ils
veulent et qui avait une lambretta parce
que pour emballer les graisses animales
d'avoir la lambretta
et alors vous avez vécu il faut le dire
on peut dire cette première expérience
alors votre copine and i ll pousser des
cris formidable ça lui plaisait beaucoup
vous en fait vécu c'est un peu comme
l'extraction d'une dent de sagesse - 106
non mais c'est la vie la vie oui j'avoue
que c'est pas de meilleur souvenir avant
que des puces la mort comment ça s'est
passé le vôtre
non je vais je obligé je pose des
questions tellement insensé aux gens y
sont obligés de répondre comme les
pauses s'était disloqué whisky à gogo à
jean lesbats et alors il y avait un
disque était going home des rolling
stones qui doit 11 minutes 35 et j'ai
profité de ces onze minutes parce que
vous étiez d'izieu qu'il soit 4 heures
du matin des fois cinq heures j'ai
profité de séances minutes pour m'enfuir
dans la pinède de juan les pins qui est
en face au whisky à gogo et donc ça a
duré voyez quoi d'éjaculation précoce la
première mais un jour je continue ce
soir de bernadette lafont mais un jour à
nîmes à l'endroit même où vos parents
s'étaient rencontrés vous rencontrez le
cinéma en la personne de gérard blain
satu quo n'est pas gérable à genzyme
français alors ils étaient là parce
qu'ils étaient venus répéter une pièce
pour les arènes de nîmes jules césar et
avec arme entier et stéphane audran il y
avait gérard lebovici comprends pas trop
pourquoi m'ont accusé la figuration
on voulait être acteur gérard leibovitz
avant d'être acteur non finalement il
était situationniste c'est bizarre comme
quoi entre un autre jeu ouais et alors
donc gérard blain il faut dire les
choses il avait une voiture noire avec
l'intérieur rouge évidence et vous à
combien va la changer complètement
séduit alors voilà bon bain limonade
baiser le mariage se profile
et là évidemment d'eni vont commencer à
chuchoter elle se marie avec une vedette
de paris évidemment il ya des jalousies
il ya des lettres de corbeaux qui arrive
chez vous pas fait c'est vrai maintenant
c'est vrai dans la lignée des lettres
qui arrive chez vos parents bien sûr
bien sûr en disant en toute façon elle
est enceinte c'est pour ça qu'elles se
marient n'hésitent pas du tout en simple
un jour gérard blain vient demander
votre main à vos parents et la première
fois choisi de le dire parce que d'abord
il faut fait l'amour avec lui vous lui
fait croire que vous êtes viège et je me
suis dit si je lui dis que non il va
être tellement bac c'est oui je savais
déjà que les hommes étaient extrêmement
chatouilleux sur cette histoire de bits
donc
donc voila vous l'épouser mais lui en
fait est obsédé bernadette bernadette
lui est obsédé par le fait que vous ayez
très envie de faire du cinéma il avait
été marié avec et stella blain savait
pas duré longtemps et vous disais toi au
moins tu est pas comme tout cecon tu
veux pas devenir actrice alors que
c'était le rêve de votre vie en mer il
vous comprenez bien gérable voilà donc
que vous faites quelques photos en
maillot de bain pour mettre du beurre
dans les épinards parce qu'il n'est pas
non plus des cachets mirobolants gérable
à et puis vous rencontrez il vous
présente l'équipe des cahiers du cinéma
c'était le début de votre de votre
carrière
yaman ascension fulgurante mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai et d'ailleurs vous vite
s'il m'avait présenté verneuil
autant-lara j'aurais fait une autre
carrière quoi mais il vous a présenté
les gens des cahiers du cinéma
alors on a tous y tenait en pharmacie
télé les plus grands par les premiers du
genre n'a pas présenté enfin on les a
connus et on a tourné les films voilà
ensemble alors vous avez tourné en 57
les mistons de françois truffaut avoir
en 59 sortie du beau serge avec gérard
blain qui de chabrol 60 les bonnes
femmes se voient qui voilà après bon on
était tous les grands films la nouvelle
vague
on vous appelait à l'époque la vamp
villageoise ça c'était quand le beau
serge est sorti ils ont dit ça et ils
ont dit 600 comique arrêt c'est mieux
vaut villageoise est alors hervé guibert
des années plus tard vous appelez la
bardot [ __ ] ça fait boum il a écrit un
très beau paquet hervé guibert mais
voilà vous étiez la petite fiancée du
cinéma français comme on dit quoi
c'était vous et alors vous avez une
explication de la nouvelle vague qu'elle
seulement extraordinaire vite qu'on fait
la nouvelle vague c'est parce qu'on
avait inventé une nouvelle pellicule qui
s'appelait l'atrix et qu'en fait on
pouvait filmer dehors sans maquillage en
lumière c'est vrai c'est pas une
révolution technique
ouais sinon avant c'était pas possible
cinq mois ou dix ans avant bien sûr
c'est toujours marrant quand on explique
quelque chose d'artistique en fait par
une innovation technique c'est comme
aujourd'hui on invente des caméras tout
petit qui filme la nuit donc on peut
faire des émissions différentes de
celles d'avant
voilà l époque j'ai failli tourner à
bout de souffle
oui parce que ils voulaient jean seberg
pour faire le rôle qu'elle a fait
d'ailleurs et il imaginait la paire quoi
les garçons la fille est donc avec jean
seberg c'était belmondo et puis à
d'autres comme jean seberg était sous
contrat avec preminger à olemps ii pour
des années il y avait un moment où
c'était compliqué et ça a failli ne
passèrent et à ce moment là moi je
tournais à double tour avec chabrol à
aix-en-provence et il est descendu et il
m'a dit si je peux pas avoir jean donc
je change le couple et est ce que vous
pourriez faire avec aznavour souhaité
drôle à blizzard alors gérard blain vous
reproche de plus en plus votre liaison
avec le 7ème art il est il est jaloux en
fait il est jaloux du fait que vous
faites si le volume actrice
il m'a renvoyé après le beau serge et
moi il vous obliger à dire que vous
aviez dit ce temps combien de vieux
19-12 avait sorti citoyen le plus averti
je pense film parce que c'était là blanc
quand il était tellement je crois qu'il
était tombé aussi amoureux de moi parce
que j'avais 16 ans et demi ouais donc il
n'avait pas envie qu'ils puissent sur ce
vous tomber enceinte vous fait avorter
parce que vous dites d'ailleurs pas
question de garder l'enfant de nos
amours défuntes
et puis voilà ça se termine comme ça
avec gérard blain et l'armée ont ça se
termine pas comme ça parce que resterons
a mis toute notre vie ah bon et toujours
en service
je n'avais pas saisi oui on s'entendait
beaucoup mieux quand on n'est plus
ensemble
ce que je ne pouvais pas être la femme
qui voulait avoir c'est à dire une femme
qui reste à la maison
il la trouvait après une formule oui
marie hélène oui c'est le pain et marc
girard il est mort longue et johary
serrurier absolument voilà vous
rencontrer 12km v ski alors ça c'est
terrible
un slave comme son nom l'indiqué non pas
du tout
en droit c'est parce l'accord et l'avoir
maintien à mahdia donc c'était un
sculpteur artiste maudit qui vous fait
trois enfants que vous pondent est comme
ça les gars présents comme une poule
pond disait pas exactement alors une
lettre à la poste ne fume pas je n'ai
pas vu passer ces trois mois et la soupe
est la victoire
mais attendez là là là l'heure est grave
il nous faisait peur un peu ce dur canon
il faisait peur un peu détient peu
envoûté par lui mais quelque chose de
compliqué complètement
je vous avais décidé être honnête ça me
fait rire non mais avec un couteau
c'est vrai que c'est un style et j'ai
loupé les initiés
et donc voilà alors vous avez marre jour
d'habiter dans cette baraque à 50 bande
de paris de ne pas fait pour ça tous vos
potes et vos copines vous dit qu'est ce
que tu fais là bas donc vous finissez
par revenir
et là votre carrière redémarre et où
fait ce film merveilleux qu'est la
fiancée du pirate et ensuite vous faites
la maman et la [ __ ]
et là vous évidemment tout le monde ait
survécu parce qu'on attend vous fassiez
la [ __ ] et vous faites la maman un an
plus tard
antistar voilà et puis après on fait de
nombreux films soient pas tous cités
dont les fronts t qui vous a rapporté un
césar en latitude air et un jour et là
j'en arrive à vous mesdemoiselles un
jour vous découvrez le théâtre vous
aussi ces requins joal monte
vous montez sur une sur une scène de
théâtre et vous avez une espèce de
sensations comme ça complètement inédite
pour vous une exaltation extraordinaire
et vous dites c'est comme au cinéma
quand j'ai commencé qu'on disait moteur
non j'ai pas dit ça
tout va mal à doukan même annulé alors
je suis doux comme un agneau les camps
bien de chanter fernandel si je lui dis
quoi vous savez je me souviens très bien
je me suis dit j'ai fait un aveu comme
ça une sorte d'élan mystique un peu
disons j'étais derrière je n'ai juste
pas c'est pour jouer cette comtesse
sanglante dont qui était le premier rôle
et j'ai dit je veux bien ne plus jamais
faire de cinéma si je peux toujours
faire du théâtre voilà et d'ailleurs est
d'ailleurs 5 janvier 2002 vous allez
jouer donc les eaux de patrick lui non
au petit théâtre de paris
alors comment es tu t'es tu voulais
faire le pitch alors la situation au
début de la pièce
c'est un jeune homme qui est dans une
sorte de studio d'enregistrement qui
tourne en rond on sent qu'il a tant qu
il est angoissé et l'interphone sonne il
dit c'est toi pierre et la réponse est
non ce n'est pas pierre ces mamans c'est
moi maman et donc j'arrive là c'est mon
fils je n'avais pas vu depuis 10 ans lui
est ravagée parce que il est dans un
grand grand grand chagrin d'amour
et moi je viens lui dire que je sais
qu'il est [ __ ] et ces deux personnes qui
se raccroche très très très très fort là
dessus mais en même temps ça permet
d'ouvrir plein de tiroirs et spar et
spar c'était un grand film sur en fait
il est homosexuel mais pour être autre
chose c'est une mère 1 6 1
et ça va loin quoi et c'est très beau ça
s'appelle les os et écrit par patrick
l'union c'est au petit théâtre de paris
ya aussi une jeune fille qui est donc la
science et du fils qui donne un espoir à
la mer mais en fait ça va être un
mariage blanc à ce que les sri lankaise
et qu'il faut qu'elles aient des papiers
c'est c'est comme ça pour qu'elle voit
la cbc les histoires de ce film
de cette pièce merci barils